good evening blackberry fans welcome to  the very first broadcast live from  Billabong - good evening everyone  I really hope you're ready because we're  in for a bigger stronger blood your  blood ball experience forever that is  true Bob now let's see we'll be playing  this new season's first match the white  one tree first versus the Dow stock  classic matches the Rivas are a long way  from their glory days a long way I'd  cease order trips to the realm of chaos  any chance to meet us within this match  Dark Souls yes there's more chance of  you having a heart  the pass to a black or black work  shouldn't terrible  camera not keep it here on cabal vision  HD there's so much more to come about  this amazing new season of Blood Bowl so  stay tuned  you